former president trump visits the
texas-mexico border today to highlight a
recent jump in illegal immigration
more than 180 000 migrants were stopped
along
the southwest border in may more than
any other month in the past
three years think about that for just a
second cbs news took an early morning
ride along the border in south texas
yesterday
in just a few hours we saw we saw more
than 200 people cross
into the state of texas maria villarreal
met a gun caring conservative pastor
who does what he can to bring immigrants
food and water right now it's about 10
30.
we're driving down to the edge of the
river
pastor luis silva drives the banks of
the rio grande river several times a
week looking to help migrant families
despite his political views i'm a guy
that is trying to show the love of
christ
but at the same time i respect our laws
moments after we arrive at the riverbank
a raft with
five people pulls up the first of
several families to come ashore
they jump out and less than a minute
later their guy turns the raft around
ready to pick up another group in mexico
is there a concern that this could
continue to get worse
yes because like i say what
the narrative that that is used he has
repercussions like i said
he had consequences and by the narrative
you mean
empathy that is coming from the
administration
yes among the dozens of parents and
children we saw
was teresita elena she's nine years old
and traveled with her family from
nicaragua for more than a month to get
here
she got here by car and also um
pastor silva gives the group water and
food before they walk to a makeshift
processing site set up by border patrol
there is well over 200 people here
men women and children they will go from
these lines they'll be processed
by border patrol and then they will be
separated and taken to certain
facilities depending on their age and if
they came with a family or
if they're an unaccompanied minor to
fight the rising immigration numbers
texas governor greg abbott is asking for
donations to help the state build a
border wall
silva supports the border wall but also
believes the immigration system needs an
overhaul
they need to come up with a solution and
people will come as long as there's an
opening
the former president will be meeting up
with texas governor greg abbott and
about two dozen other republican
lawmakers later today
here in south texas they will be meeting
up at a portion of the border wall
that is not complete this is
construction that started but was
actually stopped back in january when
the biden administration
took over tony maria thank you very much
powerful reporting along the border
there and i think the pastor may be on
to something compassion is a policy
everyone can get behind
thank you again the